what you need to know on this thursday
or for chris friday begins in new
england how about this they finally had
their chit chat
tommy and bill belichick on the
telephone now tom curran says it
happened on tuesday that the
conversation was not particularly
productive and that bill belichick was
all business what a shock look i'm not
taking a shot at our buddy tom curran's
report but what a shock that when
talking business bill belichick would be
anything other than wait for it
all business right nobody is going to
rattle bill belichick or get him out of
business mode during working hours it's
just not possible really it's hard to
get him out of that mode i think in you
know non-working hours this is just how
his brain works he lives it he's a
curmudgeon as we've talked about you
know and yes he's not going to sit there
and and he prays on on tom brady you
know he did that with the nfl 100 watch
the show he talks about tom all the time
there you know but again he's still the
chance he's going to be his leader his
head coach so he's still going to treat
it like that even though that
relationship is probably more special
than we realize or more special than
other relationships ever but i do find
it interesting again and one belichick
yeah it's not going to be real
productive belichick's not going to do
anything until he has a good feel for
what brady wants to do and maybe what
teams are out there and the market is
really saying for brady and making sure
brady's appetite is fulfilled that way
to go okay you sure nothing out there is
like you know you like all right come
back let's talk let's get into it and i
think that's what's interesting other
thing i find interesting here is like
you know i mean tom tom curran you know
he's the man up there in boston i gotta
think he got this from somebody in
brady's camp right i mean i don't think
belichick called tom curran and was like
hey things weren't real productive today
you know what i mean it's got to be
somebody from there uh so that's why i
find it interesting with brady right now
he's kind of controlling the narrative a
little bit here
you're you're moving your finger that
giant e.t finger
your giant e.t middle finger you're
moving it dangerously close to a third
rail in this business where it's not
regarded as kosher to speculate on how
people know oh yes you're right you're
right i know i know so you're aware yes
but it was pr but all that said it was
probably tom brady's dad but but just
just so you're aware we should not
engage in those kinds of conversations
um what what would the conversation even
be between bill belichick and tom brady
what's there to discuss at this point if
they're talking directly because brady
has an agent now we know he cuts his own
deals usually directly with robert kraft
but but what's there even to discuss
right now between tom brady and bill
belichick
you're right i don't really know other
than what tom is thinking a little bit
and maybe just giving him an update
there you know bill's a very honest guy
uh and he's the type of guy that's gonna
shoot shoot you straight you know no
matter who you are that way and
especially when it comes to football so
he's probably letting them know where
they are as far as you know money wise
things like that i would think it's more
almost a cordial hey let's just let's
just check the box say we talked we got
a little feel for what's going on but
there's just still so much left to be
digested here and i don't know i mean
you know with the tennessee titans or
they how much of a player are they over
tom brady i don't know you know i do
still find it odd that they facetimed
him out of the first row of the syracuse
basketball game this past weekend you
know the 49er thing you know it's not
going away it seems to be real i don't
hear the 49ers coming out and denying it
either so that's where i start to go
well there's smoke there's fire and i
don't see anybody adamantly saying no
way that's never going to happen so that
makes me think that think it is real
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports